did you know that this guy who can turn
into a chicken has an even higher bouncy
than Frankie or that many bounties
contain hidden messages in Japanese or
that poor Chopper who's always mistaken
for the pet of the straw hats actually
isn't the character with the smallest
bouncing all of One Piece because
instead that really sad title actually
goes to Beppo here the orange jumpsuit
wearing polar bear from Topanga lost
crew with a mere 500 berries bevel has a
smaller Bounty than any other character
in one piece which is kind of crazy
considering Beppo's Fierce sulong
transformation in the manga however it
does seem that since bepho is a mink the
world government thinks he's just an
actual polar bear I guess instead of the
Navigator of the heart Pirates and
honestly the case is very similar for
the second lowest Bounty as well Tony
Tony Chopper who the government thinks
is just a straw Hat's pets however after
the raid on onigashima his Bounty was
actually raised to at least 1 000
berries twice the amount of people's
bouncy and if the government knew the
truth about jopper and that he was
actually one of the smartest members of
the crew and definitely smarter than his
own Captain I'm sure his Bounty would be
much much higher and while it might be a
little bit hard for some of you to
imagine just how much 1000 berries is
and since berries are worth
approximately the same as Japanese Yen
this means that turning in Chopper right
now would earn you around 6 Euros 36
Cents or 6.91 sound like not exactly a
lot but now let's make a massive lead
from 1 000 to 3 million two hundred
thousand berries where we're clearly not
in joke bouncing territory anymore now
this bounty belongs to Mr four of
Baroque Works who you might remember as
the guy who shattered all of usop's
bones with this baseball bat and just
above him is this guy here at 3 million
four hundred thousand his name is
Portuguese and we met him in Luffy's
childhood flashback this guy here worked
for the pirate blue Gem and his Bounty
was fittingly low for someone who lost
the fight to literally two children Ace
and Sabo but uh what can I say that's
what you sign up for when you pick on
kid Luffy and by pick on I mean
violently torture kid Luffy not a
respectable 5 million berries is the
first pirate that we ever saw Luffy beat
up in the series iron mace alvida it's
kind of wild though that this is the
last confirmed bounty we have for her
because one can only speculate that it's
probably gonna be higher now that she's
technically a yonko crew member working
under buggy and poor chew it must be sad
to have the lowest bounty on the arlong
Pirates separated here from all your
crewmates with only 5 million five
hundred thousand berries but honestly
who knows what your fellow fishermen did
to get that much of a higher bouncy than
you and again slightly above him at 7
million there's a really unique
occurrence this bounty actually belongs
to the nyaban brothers sham and Buchi
who worked for Captain Kudo who you
might remember was the main antagonist
of the sir Village Arc where the crew
recruited Usopp and like these two share
their bouncy and as far as I can see
these brothers are the only characters
in all of One Piece where two different
characters share a single a bouncy
between them so I guess for all you
bounty hunters out there it's a two for
one deal or not really anyways after
them it's right back over to Baroque
works with Miss Valentine who boasts a
bounty of seven million 500 000 berries
and above her is Luffy's caretaker slash
the closest thing I guess that he had to
a mother curly Dada now this mountain
Bandit who raised Luffy and Ace after
GARP dropped them off here in the middle
of the Goa Kingdom as a quite impressive
Bounty of seven million 800 000 berries
and shockingly with a bounty above
everyone we've seen so far is the very
first Bounty that we ever saw in the
whole series and it's another Mountain
Bandit just like dadan but without her
heart of gold that's right we're talking
about higuma here aka the guy that
Shanks absolutely destroyed in chapter
one of one piece with the Bounty of a
clean 8 million berries and exactly
tight with that mountain Bandit is the
second best swordsman in Fishman Island
hachan he earned his Bounty as part of
the arlang Pirates but I do wonder if
the Marines would still honor that deal
now that hachon is just a humble
takoyaki salesman however I'm pretty
sure that this next penalty has
definitely been erased because it
belongs to Django the hypnotist he had a
9 million very bouncy while he was
working for the black cat Pirates but
now that he switched sides to the
Marines he's officially bouncy free I
hope who knows what cross Guild has been
up to but still at 9 million berries as
far as we know at least is another
arlong pirate Kuro Obi aka the guy with
the pigtails that Sanji fought and now
already moving into the tents at 10
million berries we have two more Pirates
this random guy who attacked a childhood
Trafalgar law during his flashback and
Baroque Works Mr five AKA explosive
Lenny Kravitz I guess next with 11
million berries we have the heaviest
member of the donkey shot family and the
one with by far the lowest Bounty and
with an inexplicity higher bouncy than a
member of doflamingo's crew is gin Dawn
Creek subordinate from The baratia Arc
at 12 million berries and then jumping
up another 2 million for 14 is yet
another Baroque Works member there
really all at the bottom the mole woman
here miss Merry Christmas and with a
strange number 14 million three hundred
thousand berries we have blue Jam from
Luffy's childhood flashback then at 50
million we have this little half
fighting Fishman freak again from the
donkey shot family at 60 million we have
Captain Kuro himself the pirate who
wrecked havoc on usop's Hometown syrup
village with 17 million though we have
the main villain of the baratia arc Don
Creek and for that exact same Bounty is
this super random guy who was on sale at
the Saba ODI auction house now for 20
million though we have the highest
bounty in the entire East blue besides
Luffy of course which is arlong as a
former member of the sun Pirates Who was
causing Terra in kokoyashi Village no
pirate was considered more dangerous in
the weakest of the Seas his Bounty
likely would have been much higher if he
hadn't been keeping a relatively low
profile in the East blue and regularly
paying off the Marines there and
actually another Infamous pirate with a
bouncy off at least 20 million is Jesus
Burgess the captain of Blackbeard's
first chip now obviously since blackbit
has since then become a full-fledged
yonko I imagine that burj's Bounty is at
least a little bit higher than 20
million but that's the last confirmed
Bounty that we actually have for this
character and also two more characters
who have the same amount of 20 million
are actually the two yeti cool Brothers
these really random Giants from Punk
hazards but our next character is this
monkey man who loves to salvage from the
Jaya Arc with 23 million berries and
then at 24 we have three characters who
share it and they're three of the most
random characters you could possibly
think of the Waxman Mr three big mom's
daughter Charlotte Lola and one of one
piece's silliest villains which is of
course Foxy the Silver Fox and just
above them though with 25 million is
Montblanc Cricket the descendant of
Nolan the liar who I guess earned that
Bounty through the terrible crime of
diving in the sea I guess huh now the
captain of the fake straw hats when we
returned to sabaori archipelago after
the time skip had a bounty of 26 million
which is really just sad I mean this
fake Straw Hat couldn't even earn the
amount of Luffy's very first Bounty and
we also have another Baroque Works agent
with Miss golden week aka the painter
girl who worked with Mr three and who
had a bouncy off 29 million berries and
for reference right above that is
Luffy's very first bounty in these blue
30 million I mean just think for a
second Luffy's bouncy first bouncy was
higher than every character we've talked
so far in this entire video before he
even entered the grand line and just
above that at 31 million we have the
most explosive member of dolphy's crew
and 32 is the Pinnacle of friendship Mr
tube on clay and his former spiky Ally
Miss Double finger actually had a bounty
of quite impressive 35 million berries
and then we have actually a couple of
characters sharing 36 million first is
this other salvaging gorilla for Jaya
and at the same price we also have the
Colosseum fighter Bobby Funk as well as
this very random guy who got beaten up
quite badly by the Galileo ship rides in
water 7. then at 38 million we have this
very fashionable friend of Bellamy who
do Flamingo then puppeteered into a
fight with his bestie and at 40 million
berries each are the Boa Hancock sisters
sandersonia and Marigold both of Amazon
Lily but obviously worth more than the
Two Sisters of the pirate Empress at 42
million is this very random guy from
Jaya and with a price of at least 42
million though there's the demon Sheriff
Lafitte men just like Jesus bird you can
only guess that this high-ranking member
of Blackbeard's crew has also seen a big
prize hike since he became the
subordinate of a yonko but 42 million is
the last update we've seen on his bounty
in the story so far one thing for sure
he's gonna be a lot higher than this 52
million Berry bouncy that belongs to
this random Blackbeard Allied captain
who attacked the Lucia Kingdom and got
completely stomped by the four
revolutionary Army commanders then at 57
million is the smaller and angry of the
two Funk Brothers Kelly and Ona of
possibly the weirdest devil fruit in the
entire series the jacket jacket fruit
but not to be outdone at 58 million is
the most hard-boiled member of the
donkey cut Pirates Senor pink then this
pirate who we met as a slave when we
were first introduced to the celestial
dragons on Saba ODI is worth 60 million
berries and at 61 is the oldest member
of Donkey Kong's family Lao ji then
auger the sniper of the blackbit Pirates
is another yonko Commander that we can
only assume has received a major Bounty
increase but for now his last confirmed
Bounty is at least 64 million berries
and these two lower ranking members of
the straw hat Grand Fleet are both also
sharing a 67 million Berry bouncy and
honestly at this point we're definitely
starting to see a bit of a pattern here
but doc Q also probably has a higher
Bounty now however for now the death god
of the Blackbeard Pirates has a bouncy
off at least 72 million this super
random crap hand guy who got completely
wrecked by the new Fishman Pirates was
actually worth 73 million which is kind
of insane crocodile's second in command
Des bones is worth 75 million for his
time in the criminal organization
Baroque works and might be worth even
more now that he's a high-ranking member
of the Cross guilds again another yonko
crew and actually let's take a minute to
compare that amount to some other
currencies so 75 million yen for my
Western viewers for example is about 518
000 US dollars or 476 000 Euros so
turning that bones into the government
could give you enough money to buy a
pretty nice house in cash Robin's mom
Nico alvia is worth 79 million as we
know anyone familiar with aspects of the
Void century and the pony glyphs is
definitely heavily wanted by the
government and now we're starting to get
up there but trust me we've barely even
scratched the surface of the
unbelievably High Bounties in one piece
brownbeard objectively the worst of all
the characters who are a color and a
beard is worth this very peculiar Bounty
amount of 80 million 60 000 in a way
that the government feel like they
needed to add sixty thousand the world
may never know and this random rookie
who joined up with the fake straw hats
was actually worth 88 million and Gotti
Capone beige's crewmate and man with a
machine gun for an arm I guess is worth
90 million at 92 we have this other
rookie who joined the fake straw hats
and is doing his best mummy impression
and Rockstar one of shanks's
subordinates in the red hair Pirates is
actually worth 94 million and the owner
of the longest tongue in all of One
Piece a veto of the fire tank Pirates
has a bouncy of 95 million however now
it's finally time for some crewmates to
share an equal Bounty amount after all
sharing is caring and sharing the Bounty
of exactly 99 million each are the top
three Executives of the donkey shot
family Diamante Pika and treble these
three crazy powerhouses are the
centerpiece of doflamingo's hold over
dressrosa running much of the political
Machinery of the island and these three
were even responsible for taking in a
yondo flamingo and grooming him into the
maniacal evil that he is today now
that's what I call Fantastic parenting
and so now finally we've already reached
a benchmark of 100 million berries a
bounty shared by two captains of the
Giant Warrior Pirates Dory and braggy
now who knows how much higher their
Bounty would be if they've been pirating
for the last past Century instead of
dueling each other on little garden and
now that they're hanging out with their
best buddy Shanks though maybe they'll
finally get a giant-sized bouncy to
match their well giant size also with
100 million was strawhead Luffy after he
defeated sir crocodile in Alabaster
after defeating a warlord the government
really started to take him more
seriously as a threat but that would be
nothing compared to his next Bounty and
level 5 of imple down only houses
prisoners with bouncy over 100 million
in case you didn't know so while we
don't know their exact Bounty numbers
these three characters here have at
least that for instance there is this
guy who joined up with buggy after the
prison break as well as the
revolutionaries Emporio ivankov and
Inazuma who were housed in level 5
before moving on to the secret level 5
newcomerland now the bounties are
getting so high that we're getting into
yonko subordinate territory actually
because with 105 million 500 000 berries
is one of the first big man crew members
that we actually met and one of those
who had actually the least impact on the
story bobbin another wave crossed a 100
million threshold we're also starting to
highlight some supernovas starting with
the one we've seen the least in the
story Mad Monk Roche who last time at
least we checked had a 108 million Berry
bouncy Charlotte mondor another big mom
subordinate and wielder of the book
devil fruit is at 120 million or lumbus
one of the major commanders of the straw
hat Grand Fleet who brought his 4 300
men andaluffy's control has a bounty of
148 million in US Dollars that would be
around 1 million twenty two thousand
dollars so turning in Olympus would make
you an American millionaire sadly for
Europe though that's just gonna be
around 940 000 last time we checked but
that's nothing compared to this pirate
with a staggering 190 million which it's
Caribou oh no not Caribou his brother
now this just goes to show that bounties
don't always correspond to strength I
think because karibu didn't earn his
high Bounty from his power but he and
his brothers just love of killing
Marines I guess and mounting into the
next spot with 195 is Bellamy the owner
of the spring spring fruit who honestly
I was kind of completely surprised by I
kind of forgot that he had such a high
bouncy and sharing a bounty of 200
million are the ultimate straw hat
superfan bartolomeo and the Supernova
that just can't stop laughing kill her
and just for frame of reference that
makes these two worth 10 are Longs each
now three random characters also happen
to have a bounty of 210 million that are
in no way related to each other we have
karibu famous for being the other guy's
brother squirt the Judas of the
Whitebeard allies and donsai another
command of the straw hat Grand Fleet and
also known recently as another Charles
hitter then x-drake another Supernova
and secret member of Sword has a bounty
of 222 million and since he's secretly
working for the Marines though who knows
how legit That Bouncy actually is but
since we know that sword members
technically have resigned from the
Marines we bet that you could make a
pretty penny by bringing in this
Allosaurus next at 230 million is Fisher
tiger and after Fisher tiger climbed the
red line with his bare hands and free to
slice from arijua We're actually
surprised that his Bounty doesn't hit
the billion Mark but once we get to that
point you'll see just how crazy some of
the Pirates who have that amount there
truly are page one comes in at 290 and
is one of the members of the flying six
he's one of kaido's top subordinates and
has a bouncy to match that and only a
little higher at 293 million is morally
of the Revolutionary Army now obviously
a revolutionary deserves a big Bounty
but she also has the distinction of
being one of the few people to ever
break out of imple down well before that
massive Breakout that Luffy did of
course Bartholomew Kuma the king turned
revolutionary turned warlord turned
cyborg turned slave holy hell um has a
bounty of 296 million and three
characters that share a bounty of 300
million are the first Caesar Clown whose
evil scientist exploits and many weapons
of mass destruction silently earned that
high Bounty then the next two though are
the two brothers who Caesar would
absolutely not like to run into lest he
be imprisoned by big mom again and that
would be Charlotte oven and Charlotte
daifuku with the triplet Brothers of
katakuri and two of big mom's strongest
non-sweet commanded children however as
you'll know these aren't the only
characters who've had a 300 million
Berry bouncy because this was also
Luffy's bouncy after the straw Hat's
all-out assault on Enos Lobby where they
officially declared war against the
world governments Lindbergh another
revolutionary Army Commander has earned
a bounty of 360 million for his
rebellious actions against the world
government as well and three characters
also share the Bounty amount of 320
million the first two are members of the
worst generation first basil Hawkins who
served under kaido as one of his
Headliners and judging by those marks on
his forehead the most literal headliner
you know what I mean second we have
jewelry Bonnie the daughter of pathology
mikuma and which showed at whatever part
of Kuma is still conscious is very proud
of his daughter for achieving a higher
Bounty than her old man and the third
pirate with a 320 million Barry bouncy
is a former warlord gecko Moria turns
out stealing and reanimating corpses is
a severe crime who knew and next the 330
million Berry bounties also go to two
different Pirates the first being pekoms
the Ming subordinate of big mom and the
second being another commander of the
straw hat Grand Fleet Cavendish of the
beautiful Pirates and actually donkey
Kyoto Flamingo feels surprisingly low on
this list considering how many more
characters with higher bounties we have
left of course we have to factor in that
his Bounty of 340 million was frozen
when he was granted warlord status but
had his Bounty been able to increase I'm
sure his position as an underworld
broker and arms dealer would have earned
him a way higher Bounty and actually he
might just be able to call in a favor
with the celestial dragons to keep it
nice and low if he wants though I guess
next at 350 million there are two more
supernovas first being cabone beige the
number one dad in all of One Piece which
isn't really that high of a bar to cross
honestly and second is gretchman a pooh
who really ought to see a dentist about
those uh weird piano teeth I think now
the fact that we're just now getting
into our first non-chopper Straw Hat
really shows you just how Infamous our
crew has become now that Luffy has
officially become an emperor because cat
burglar Nami has a bouncy of
366 million and I'm sure that she's glad
that she's on the relatively lower end
of the spectrum compared to some of her
crewmates Pedro R.I.P had a bounty of
382 million before his death on whole
cake islands and up next we have two
more straw hats Soul King broke with a
bounty of 383 million and Cyborg Frankie
here with has a bounty of 394 million
fitting for the two of the crewmates who
went up against the terrifying big mom I
mean what other pirate can say that they
motorcycle big mom in the face and
Brooke managed to do the impossible he
spent a night in big mom's bed and
actually survived even though he's
already dead
and then sharing a bounty of 400 million
are the hard-headed ulti from kaido's
crew and karasu the Revolutionary Army
commander and wielder of the sutsut
fruit and as you will know 400 million
was also the Bounty that Luffy earned
after leading an unprecedented prison
break out of imple down and
participating in the giant marineford
war and big mom's eggy subordinate Baron
samago has a bounty of
429 million which wow quite impressive
for this man another revolutionary Army
Commander Bello Betty is worth 457
million fitting for someone with the
perfect fruit for inciting riots against
the government I'd say in sazaki of
kaido's flying 6 has a bounty of 472 and
actually since we're here another member
of the flying six black Maria is worth
480 million an amount that she shares
with the former warlord and alleged son
of Whitebeard Edward Vivo then we have
drum roll please the sniper King himself
got Usopp who's our first pirate to
cross the half billion threshold with
500 million berries and honestly this is
kind of insane because that means that
one usop is worth 1 million beppos now
of course this is also the number that
Luffy earned after the straw hats the
throne doflamingo and freed the island
of dressrosa from the corrupt warlord
easel one of the nine red scabbards and
a former command of the whitebeat
Pirates was actually worth 510 million
before their death on onigashima Don
chinjau former enemy of GARP and current
Ally of Luffy is worth 542 million which
just goes to show the pointer the head
the higher the bounce he goes who's who
kaido subordinate who was formerly a
member of cp9 has a bounty of 546
million as the person who was held
responsible for uh protecting Luffy's
devil fruit little ores Jr a descendant
of the ancient giant orus has a bounty
of 550 million a bounty that he actually
shares with his friend Port Gus D Ace as
a division commander of the Whitebeard
Pirates and the son of gold D Roger
himself Ace definitely has earned his
massive Bounty I wonder if akano tried
to get the money from the government
anyways Charlotte's snack is one of the
big mom children we still haven't met he
was one of her sweet commanders before
he was defeated by the The Mad Monk
Rouge off-screen prior to whole cake
islands and one thing that we do know
though about snack is that his Bounty is
600 million and really just a little bit
above that at 602 million is the
Revolutionary Army Chief of Staff the
flame Emperor Sabo as the second in
command for the biggest thorn in the
world government side it's actually no
surprise that this bounty is this High I
do suspect a bit of an increase soon
though because I mean we're considering
that Sabo learned the government's
Greatest Secret during the reverie
Charlotte pero Sparrow big mom's eldest
son reaches a quite impressive Bounty of
700 million higher than one of the sweet
commanders even though he doesn't hold
that title himself however not as high
as the next big mom child on the list
which is Charlotte cracker who gave even
gear for Luffy a tough battle at whole
cake island and has a bounty of 860
million we can actually take a short
break from the Charlotte family though
because we now have the devil child
herself Nico Robin who has a bounty of
930 million being one of the only people
in the world who can actually decipher
the pony glyphs Robin is one of the most
dangerous individuals for the world
governments therefore she does earn a
bounty just as high as many characters
who are physically much much stronger
than her and then slightly just above
Robin is yet another sweet Commander
Charlotte smoothie with 932 million but
now next comes our first one billion
Berry Bounty before meeting this
character we could hardly conceive a
bounty this High honestly and we'd never
seen anything like it in the series with
a 1 billion Berry bouncy is one of
kaido's All-Stars Jack the drought and
next Black like Sanji is our very first
Straw Hat to break the billion being
worth 1 billion 32 million berries
however an early Bounty of sanjis is
definitely interesting to look at as
well because his Bounty poster after
this Rosa was worth 177 million and is
the only Post in the series that we've
actually seen that says only alive
instead of dead or alive in case you
don't know this was due to the
interference of the windsmoke family
whose German kingdom is a member of the
nations of the world government and
Vince milk judge wanted to to keep his
long-lost son alive as a political Pawn
to marry into the Charlotte family now
that didn't quite work out for him that
well and on his next Bounty Sanji
returned to being wanted Dead or Alive
but just above him is the first billion
very man that Luffy went head to head
with the future side master and
strongest of the big mom's children
Charlotte katakuri with 1 billion 57
million now fun fact since Luffy is
heavily associated with the number 56
which can be read as bullmu in Japanese
katakuri's Bounty having 57 million in
it was oda's way of hinting at the
mochi's user superiority to Luffy at the
beginning of their fight see Oda is
sneaky with those number plays now the
night of the sea jinbei has a bounty of
1 billion 100 million now that he's one
of the most powerful commanders of the
straw hat Grand Fleet add to that his
former status as the shichibukai and
leader of the sun Pirates and you get
someone with a resume so crazy that he's
surpassing Sanji for the third highest
bounty in the straw hat crew these
bounties are starting to make me sweat
to take on my jacket because just above
him at 1 billion 111 million
isoro who handily deserves a billion
plus bounty after taking out kaido's
second in command King maybe all of
those are supposed to be hinting at
something like how he's Luffy's uh
unofficial first mate maybe somedale
have finally earned that title for real
we can only hope and queen the plague
has a bounty of 1 billion 320 million
it's higher than even Sanji and zoro's
bounties but you have to remember that
the bounties aren't just power levels
they do also have to do with a pirate's
Threat Level both to the world
government itself and society as a whole
and so while no one is going to get food
poisoning from sanji's expertly crafted
plates Queen does have the unfortunate
habit of releasing terrible diseases of
his own design onto his victims hence
the nickname the plague then Marco the
Phoenix comes in at 1 billion 374
million who's the second former in
command of the white bit Pirates and is
powerful enough to take on King and
Queen at the same time and honestly I
got a feeling that the world government
probably wouldn't look too kindly upon
the new leader of the Whitebeard Pirates
after the marineford were pretty much
demolished the Marine headquarters
really all of this is a pretty perfect
recipe for a massive bouncy however it's
not quite as massive as king the
Wildfire who has a 1 billion 390 million
Berry Bounty and as the last known
living lunarian and a prized government
test subject who escaped from Punk
Hazard the world government has every
reason in the world to want to get King
back and actually this motivation gets
even higher when you think about the
fact that King seems to know a lot about
the history and the legend of joyboy but
then next after whole kick Island where
Luffy stormed a yonko's territory to
free Sanji he actually earned a new
Bounty of 1 billion 500 million after
being named the fifth emperor of the sea
his sixth bounty in the entire series
and above that we actually have Boa
Hancock the pirate Empress of Amazon
Lily and former Waller of the sea who is
now a new Bounty of 1 billion 659 9
million after the warlord system was
abolished she was one of the former
chichibukai who achieved a huge Bounty
with her dangerous devil fruit capable
of turning anyone to Stone and a
country's worth of haki using Warriors
at a disposal she's truly a force to be
reckoned with so crocodile is the first
Warlords that the straw hats ever fought
and was their very first true test of
strength in the grand line and now that
he's the leader of cross Guild and
actively issuing bounties on
high-profile Marines from his end he
surged to the top of the government's
most wanted list with a bounty of 1
billion 965 million berries and actually
for the next place on our list there is
a bit of a tie here for toppling the
former yonko kaido and big mom the
alliance of Monkey D Luffy used as kit
and Trafalgar law have all earned
massive bounties of 3 billion berries
really this just shows how seriously the
government are taking the worst
generation now that they've made a real
name for themselves in the new world and
this is actually Luffy's current Bounty
but I've got a feeling that it'll go
even higher before the end of the series
which is insane because it's a all 100
times higher than his original Bounty of
30 million and also we have to mention
at the same level GARP who is the first
Marine confirmed with a bounty from
Cross Guild of also 3 billion berries
just like his grandson but even above
these four is the almighty The Fearsome
buggy the clown his Bounty is now a
staggering 3 billion 189 million very
fitting for one of the four Emperors and
a prime candidate for the pirate that
will claim the one piece and become
pirate king I mean after failing upwards
all the way from the East blue this
former Cabin Boy for Roger has ascended
to the top of the pirate world and we
really don't know why and how but of
course dracul mihawk keeps him in check
or at least tries to and this is the
true Powerhouse of the Cross Guild and
the world's greatest swordsman according
to crocodile he was actually known as
the Marine Hunter before he was named
shichibukai but now that the warlord
system has been dissolved his Bounty is
now 3 billion 590 million and next up we
have another yonko with Marshall D teach
AKA Blackbeard who has a bounty of 3
billion 996 million berries Blackbeard
started his pirate career on
whitebeard's crew achieved the status of
chichibukai and broke some of the most
terrifying prisoners out of imple down
to join his crew now this would already
be worth of a huge Bounty but then you
add the fact that he's the only person
ever known to consume two devil fruits
and they're two of the most destructive
and Powerful ones in the entire story
and so after he conquered the remains of
whitebeard's old territory he
established himself as an emperor of the
sea with a massive bounty to match that
and now before we move on to the truly
most unbelievably High bounties on this
list though it's gonna be time for some
honorable mentions here because there
are some characters with still unknown
bounties that were sure would be among
the highest that have yet to be revealed
for instance what was Roxy's backspounty
we also don't know many members of the
Blackbeard red hair or Roger Pirates
bounties and we assume that the highest
Bounty belongs to the world's most
wanted man and Luffy's father Monkey D
Dragon but until we truly find out for
sure we can only speculate how crazy
high those bounties truly were because
now it's time for the top 5 highest
Bounties in one piece because at number
5 we have probably the most mysterious
character in all of One Piece red hair
Shanks worth 4 billion 48 million 900
000 berries the highest Bounty of any
living person as far as we know at the
moment in the story now why such a huge
Bounty well let's look at what we do
know about this enigmatic figure he
served on Roger's crew and he stole the
sun god Nika fruit from the world
government and gave it to Luffy moreover
though he's almost certainly connected
to the figure land family of the
celestial dragons having been found by
Roger as an infant on God Valley and
then at his insane conquer hockey feeds
and he's easily worth over 4 billion
actually I feel like he's kind of
undervalued at this point and the other
original for Empress also all possess
bounties over 4 billion Charlotte
lindlin otherwise known as big mom was
worth 4 billion 388 million berries
before her defeat on onigashima and as a
former member of the Rocks Pirates and
one of the Emperors of the sea she
cemented her status as one of the
strongest pirates in the world her soul
fruit is insanely powerful and versatile
her durability is incredible and her
taste for sweets is unparalleled but her
former rocks crew member kaido was known
as the world's strongest creature as a
young pirate he broke free from
government experimentation multiple
times at Punk Hazard and after
partnering with Orochi and conquering
the land of mono he became a yonko and
was one of the highest arms dealers in
the world even having the government
itself as a client and all of this
earned him a bounty of 4 billion 611
million 100
000 berries and to keep it going yet
another rocks crew member and the
strongest man in the world was Edward
Newgate better known as Whitebeard now
this user of the earthquake crew who was
even able to wage war against the full
forces of the world government even
while terminally ill had a impressive
Bounty of 5 billion 46 million berries
but even he can compete with the highest
known bouncing all of One Piece with a
bounty of 5 billion 664 million 800 000
is the king of the Pirates himself the
man who found love tale and started the
Golden Age of piracy Goldie Roger now to
put that into perspective that's about
38.5 million US Dollars and around 35
million euros it's too late to collect
on it but just imagine what you could do
with that amount of money and these
bounties are insanely high but if you
want to see how crazy the straw Hat's
final bounties will be at the end of the
series then you should really check out
this video right here